foreign
is up next in Mobile Alabama Frank
welcome to the show
well thank you for taking my call sure
how can we help
well I had a medical issue uh two years
ago lost my job
uh been hanging on hanging on my
little emergency fund while I was
working my snowball
that
that was depleted like almost
immediately is
um anyway
I haven't been able to pay my credit
card through my little Local Credit
Union here
and they're negotiating and they're
offered
about 50 51 percent
of what I owe okay should I take that or
do you think there's more room for
negotiation
I would take it do you have the money to
pay it
I can scrape that together I would
scrape it together and be done with it
and call it a blessing and move on with
my life
yeah right now is not the time to try to
haggle I mean you owed this money
they're willing to give you some grace
and mercy here and say hey we'll take
half of it if you got it and for that
reason I'm Gonna Take It
thank you I I was just kind of looking
for some guidance I've been listening to
guys for years and well that get you
debt free I actually
I still got the house but other than
that yeah the wife's got some little
card stuff but let's cut up the cards
and pay these things off what does she
have on her cards
I think like four grand are they is it
in collections or is it just sitting on
the balance
no we've been able to hang on to those
current so we're going to start knocking
them out now that this one's
out of the way and I do have a little
bit of income coming in finally
are you working full-time right now
because you said you were unable
medically disabled okay permanently it
just went through wow
and your wife after 15 months now is
that going to give you more margin with
disability payments
it'll let us keep current with hers so
we can pay them off
and be debt-free yeah is she working
she's unable to work due to a medical
condition my goodness is she getting any
disabilities
yeah that's tough
um why is she why it sounds like you
said the wife has cards do you guys have
separate finances are you guys on the
same page and in the same bank account
well we have a joint but
I cannot seem to uh finagle her head
around get rid of them so like a little
security blanket oh well it's not a
security blanket it's a weighted blanket
isn't it
that's what I've been trying to show her
with this one
I don't know how you're sleeping at
night under that security blanket quote
unquote when you're on disability you
can't work and you have all these
payments you got to make
it's about 23 interest probably
does she does she feel what you feel the
way you started the call is it kind of
sounded like a country song Frank like
I'm just hanging on hanging on hanging
on and that's exhausting right
it
it is
and does she feel that way
no she just thinks you know
everything is fine and that's what I
thought taking steps to we're taking uh
steps to
how old are you today in the right
direction we're both in our 50s okay and
uh you're unofficially retired because
you're unable to work so what does the
next 10 years look like for you guys
have you talked about that I'm gonna
remain debt free and if we can't get
together on this you can't remain debt
free unless she decides to become debt
free because it's we
y'all are married
the men have to not be that but I don't
want that but it may have to be
well I think you're gonna have to have a
hard conversation and go listen this is
really hard on me I'm scared we're not
safe you think we're safe with the
security blanket of a credit card I want
to be completely debt free we don't have
a lot of income coming in all we have is
this disability to get us by for the
next who knows how many years and I want
to get to safety I want to get to
financial peace and I'm willing to do
whatever it takes are you in
and I want you to have a little bit of
urgency in your voice when you say it
okay
because I want you guys to have some
dignity in retirement and not just go
well we're just hanging on we've been
hanging on like Eeyore is your spirit
animal over here
I want better for you guys and it sounds
like you guys lost hope a little while
back and we want to put a little pep in
your step give you some mojo back and go
you can have a great life but it's going
to take a little bit of short-term
sacrifice
so if there's anything you guys can even
do from home I don't know what that
looks like with your medical conditions
and disabilities but I don't want you
just relying on the government giving
you scraps off the table trying to just
get by you're worth more than that Frank